attendre mi temps allez zou
[Musique]
et mokhtar autant son ami hatem ben arfa
et car il aime autant mokhtar c'est une
autre ambiance
regardez
[Musique]
bon je te présente julien mon chat tu
connais moi enchantée qui est
photographe depuis lundi soir du coup
qui m'a contacté je la prochaine fois je
le vois mais il a appelé les autres 4 jo
écart qu'à un truc éventuellement nous
proposer oui alors avec lequel tu es
d'accord a priori voilà des choses parce
que moi je fais moi je fais des dessins
de paparazzade siège de la presse people
en soirée à ma charge en afrique
j'écoute je marche du coup j'en étais
été un peu chaud pour fermer une sorte
de fausse paparazzade
mais après ça peut être intéressant pour
les bus scolaires et se faire de
l'argent et on pourra faire une sorte de
mini scénarios entre guillemets mais de
paparazzi un peu gens ont sorti de
soirée un petit bisou dans la boue dans
la rue un truc où tu pourrait statuer
sur ce sur samba l'équipe à tous les
deux un filet d'eau je peux faire ça
pour là c'est un peu un peu peut-être
beaucoup pour toi mais mais il ya 50
1000e en cash ce serait une sorte de
forme de sextape sa sextape vidéos et
des photos on peut tirer d'un truc comme
s'ils savaient comment avoir une
serviette
oui comme un roman photo et voilà un
roman
taf et jean il m'a dit que ce serait
quelque chose pour personne et garde pas
pour lancer ce classement non mais juste
ce match la miss ne pas jeter touche à
tout juste 5 kg djelfa mulhouse ou au
cinéma il ya vraiment du bifff asper
pour le coup c'est du cash je fais moins
5000 je peux même négociations à six
sans nom de sobibor
j'ai passé un hiver tu veux jouer chez
les pros ça me va je te dis c'est pas
toi tu le vends des photos imprimées
temps non non ce ne sera pas le gpr bien
sûr mais ça doit être un commun accord
je prends une petite photo l'agencement
du but je connais pas je ne veux pas
quitter
moi je m'en fou ce que tu venais d'un
côté là quand ça passe et tout sera dota
je peux pas je peux pas m'en sortir sans
nouvelles sur la grèce justement comment
moi aussi je peux en sorte que son
joueur attend alors moi je peux faire un
truc si je te sors sens ans après on
garde l'argent et moi j'en fais comme ça
sent bon mais je peux pas prendre
je n'ai pas de dose et dr cha me dire
comme banon et je suis tout à fait pour
moi ça ne veut pas une 47.50 mulhouse et
une fouille sa copine et mal le spice
nous l'avons moi je veux bien faire tous
les journaux mais après en plus elles
sont cette fois par mois les smac 15
secondes balles et puis si tu respectes
fait les photos quand toi tu te respecte
pa on
conforme aux pourfendeurs ceci parce que
si moi j'essaie de faire croquer les
copains pour moi c'est aussi qu'ils vont
durer en ce sens
genre de tromperies moked le principe de
jeunes patriotes une voiture bon c'est
pas question principe de la santé
l'étude c'est bon quoi ouais t'as raison
il est incertain
aujourd'hui les choses chez proximus te
pendu à jaillir tu m'as dit gilles à
chaque n'ont pas caché qu'ils ont
radicalisé gaston nous allons modifier
ce dont je suis certain c'est qu'elle
arrête jamais franchement engagé mais au
regard du ballon juste pour rigoler cinq
mille balles il veut les 5000 en amour
de sa vie dorée que le rédac'chef il m'a
dit les mois comme il s'est donné pour
the wall 2005 06 il fait gratuit je
voyais ma blesure immédiat 0 qu'ils
côtoient sont montrés très présentable à
part les a pas vus battre le monde passe
à s'émousser une potacherie 1 c'est un
montage à la cua touche les lieux où ce
nom
[Applaudissements]
c'est une bombe a touché beaucoup mieux
fait que c'est ce que tu crois que tu
fais des menaces j'ai même entendu j'ai
bien entendu été cuit maintenant et qu
est ce que tu penses vraiment que ça
cesse et diffusé à la presse et que sa
fausse couche est un peu cette chose qui
parle de fusion du tout attends je peux
tu es que ça je n'ai rien à voir je peux
gagner cinq ans une monteuse de mon
attente entendu tous ces trucs cochons
avec montré deux mois c'est ça ça m'a
suffit comme ça non mais c'est pas je
vais pas le diffuser dans tous ces noms
mais la tenue du mali les truc à elle
c'est de chercher mon iphone le
somptueux lui causant une premier sillon
champion grand monde si on se moque un
peu
si on souhaite l'intérieur
bravo aux stars
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]